After taking a look a few weeks before what appeared to be 200 calories, the question arises:
How can these calories be burned? When the average person runs for a period
20 minutes will burn an average of 200 calories, but is this method the most fun
To do that? For example, why not chew gum for 18 hours
To burn those calories? But chewing gum contains about 10 calories per piece,
So if you eat a new piece each hour, it will equal the amount you eat and the amount of burn it will.
Do you like lipstick? Try to put it on your lips 1500 times to burn 200 calories. Why not use
Those sparkling lips in two hours of kissing who you love? If things develop,
You will only need an hour of sex to burn 200 calories. But before you do that, you may want to
Clean your teeth 45 times. Do you prefer a more convenient way? What do you think
Watching TV? Spend two and a half hours flipping the channels, and you will already
Burn those calories. If you watch a comedy program, you will not need more than 4 episodes of a funny series
And continuous laughter. If you feel bored and out of breath, you will need more
3 hours to burn the same quantity. You burn calories even during your sleep!
Instead of flipping channels, what do you think of surfing? You can shorten the time
To just one hour of surfing and at the same time you will get the skin color you have long wished for. But if the water enters your mouth
During that, do not worry. Because once you drink 8 glasses of fresh water you will burn
70 extra calories per day. Which means that after 3 days of drinking the amount of water recommended daily.
You will burn 200 calories. But do not try to drink the full amount in one day
Drinking large amounts of water can be dangerous to your life. If you do not want to wait for several days, try exercising
Wrap the captive cord for 15 minutes. Or if you feel happy
Why not express it by singing your favorite song 23 times? But if your voice is not appreciated
Just a shower shower, what do you think of playing "chopsticks" on the piano
For an hour and a half? Or use your fingers to print a short story of 4,800 words,
Its theme is burning 200 calories. The amount of 200 calories is only a number we chose as an example,
A pound of fat is about 3500 calories. So, keep burning calories!
But it is important to always remember that the number of calories your body actually burns during exercise
Depends on your height, weight, gender, and physical structure in general.
Remember, AsapSCIENCE released black and white shirts! You'll find the links in the Description box.
If you have an urgent question you would like to know, please feel free to ask, and join the channel to get more science videos on a weekly basis.